Good morning John, so as you may have noticed,
3D movies are all the rage, and when I say
rage, in some cases I mean actual, physical,
literal RAGE. I mean really, isn't there enough
3D in our lives already? Almost everything
I have ever known has been 3-dimensional.
Seeing a movie in 2D, that just seems like
a novelty to me, a little bit of a change
- it's refreshing!
Okay, okay. I actually do like 3D movies,
and I like to go see them with my wife, because
I like to go see all movies with my wife,
because that's just the kind of couple that
we are. And so a little while ago when I was
like, "Katherine, let's go see Tron on opening
night it's gonna be so fun!" She was like,
"Eeunnnnnn," and I didn't get it. Cause of
course it's not gonna be a great movie, but
it's gonna be a good movie, it's gonna be
fun.
And Katherine, for the first time, let it
slip that she doesn't like 3D movies because
they give her a headache and I was like "whaaaaa--?!"
So I did some research, and it turns out that
10% of Americans - that's 30 million people
- experience discomfort while watching 3D
movies, whether it's nausea, motion sickness,
or just a headache. And this was a pretty
revolutionary discovery for me. So what did
I do about it? Well, I dragged Katherine to
go see Tron and she watched it pirate-style
for half the movie and still got a headache.
But I did not ignore the needs of my better
half completely. Because I know how 3D movies
work, and I knew that it would be a relatively
simple thing to create a pair of glasses that
let you watch a 3D movie in 2D.
So later that week, I called a company that
manufactures 3D glasses. "Yo, can you make
glasses with the same polarization in each
lens?" "Yeah, I mean, we could, but that would
totally ruin the 3D effect." "By 'ruin the
effect', do you mean that it would be a crisp,
clear, 2-dimensional image?" "Uhmm... yes?"
"Excellent. I will take 5000."
I'm not kidding, I actually did it. 2D-glasses.
I am so styliiinnn'! It's kind of a big deal
for me - I had this idea, and then I made
it. I made my idea real! Katherine has watched
several movies with those and with the prototypes,
and she says it's wonderful, and I can't imagine
she's just saying that because she's my wife,
and I have to say thanks to all the people
who helped make this real. Winnie, at the
factory, Sam, for doing the web development,
Karen, for design. Tim did a great comic that's
up at 2d-glasses.com, my dad, as always, for
doing the accounting and legal stuff, and
my partner at DFTBA records, Alan, and also
Chris for helping doing the distribution and
actually getting them to the people who buy
them.
I made a thing! John, I will see you on Wednesday.
Time for the endscreen and frequently asked
questions. Question one: where can I buy them?
2d-glasses.com. Special introductory offer:
$7.99 per pair, if you buy two, you save two
dollars. Will they work with my 3D television?
No, probably not. I'm sorry, but it's a different
technology that televisions use. Will you
come on my nationally-syndicated talk show
and talk about your glasses? Oh, of course,
yeah, absolutely - though I don't like leaving
my house, so, is it okay if I Skype it in?
How on earth does that work? Well, there's
a whole page at 2d-glasses.com that explains
it all to you. Do I have to buy them online?
Yes, you do, because, it-- the internet is
where it's at, man.
Are you excited about Portal 2? Yes I am excited
about Portal 2, look, it comes out in like
12 hours! I will be playing it at youtube.com/hankgames,
the channel where I am currently rushing to
finish Portal 1, uh, because I want to finish
it before I start Portal 2.
Didn't you forget to thank someone in your
thank-yous? Yes, I did, I forgot to thank
Victor, who was instrumental in making this
whole thing happen. Why did your lighting
change so much to the endscreen? Because in
between when I filmed these two things I went
to go see Rio in 3D; it was awesome. Beautiful
in 3D, but Katherine enjoyed it too, because
it was not painful for her. Because of these.